vamos a hacer un ejemplo más complicado
de integral de línea tomemos fx y dada
por x más cuadrada esto de aquí nos
determina una superficie en el espacio
voy a intentar dibujarla aquí tenemos el
eje con un poco de perspectiva este de
aquí es el eje x si quieres lo
prolongamos para los valores negativos
hacia acá y entonces que nos queda si
intentamos dibujar esto cuando ya es
igual a cero entonces estamos en el
plano x z y simplemente nos queda una
recta porque nada más nos queda x y para
cada x tenemos una parábola entonces nos
va a ir quedando una cosa de este estilo
ahí van unas cuantas parábolas listo si
pusiéramos valores de negativos veríamos
las otras mitades de las parábolas pero
lo voy a dejar así porque nada más me
interesa el primer cuadrante entonces
vamos a tener esta superficie que se ve
más o menos así este de aquí nada más es
un intento a lo mejor luego luego haga
otro más padre pero estoy aquí es el
techo este aquí es el techo de qué cosa
pues de una integral que ahorita vamos a
hacer vamos a tomar la siguiente
trayectoria vamos a empezar en el punto
20 va a estar un poco largo el recorrido
ahí va primero vamos a recorrer un
círculo similar a como lo hicimos en el
vídeo pasado entonces vamos a recorrer
el círculo sólo que ahora el círculo
tiene radio 2 en el sentido antihorario
es decir nos vamos para allá y caemos
aquí sobre el eje y al punto 0 2 y luego
lo que voy a hacer es bajar sobre el eje
x a ver aquí lo voy a poner con color
verde hasta llegar al punto 0 0 en esa
dirección
finalmente ya que llegue al 0 0 voy a
regresar al 20 sobre el eje x algo de
este estilo a esta trayectoria la vamos
a llamar se sale y vale lo que quiero
hacer es evaluar el área de cada una de
las paredes de este pues como edificio
cuyo techo es x más cuadrada y cuya base
está dada por la trayectoria déjame
dibujar las paredes aquí tenemos una
pared verdad cuya base es el eje x luego
tenemos una pared como curva entonces
como por aquí así sobre la superficie
déjame marcarla un poco mejor creo que
aquí debería quedar un poco más arriba
como por ahí
listo esta es la segunda pared y
finalmente tenemos una tercera pared en
el plano y ez que baja hasta el 0 0
parabólica mente más o menos algo de ese
estilo déjame pintarlo con otros colores
lo voy a pintar con color rosa mexicano
entonces esa es la pared de atrás verdad
y además tenemos una pared frontal que
voy a pintar con amarillo esa está sobre
el plano x z
finalmente tenemos una tercera pared que
es como curva y la voy a pintar con pues
creo que es como azul va entonces esta
pared azul está sobre el círculo de
radio 2 si es un poco difícil de
visualizar si no tenemos un programa
gráfico para hacer el dibujo pero bueno
calculamos las áreas de las tres paredes
lo bueno es que tenemos una anotación
muy simple para expresar esto vamos a
ponerle que el área de la superficie de
esas paredes está esta y esta es igual a
una integral de línea vamos a poner la
integral de línea sobre la curva c vamos
a ponerle aquí
de f x es decir x + cuadrada todo eso de
s donde de ese es ese pequeño cambio de
la longitud sobre el contorno esto de
aquí es una integral cerrada y a veces
en la integral vas a ver un circulito
esa notación se usa mucho en libros de
física y en otros libros de aplicaciones
pero de lo único que tenemos que
acordarnos es que significa que la
trayectoria empieza en un punto y
regresa a ese mismo punto bar cómo le
hacemos para resolver esta integral pues
un buen punto para empezar es pues
definir bien bien la trayectoria con una
cierta parametrización tenemos tres
piezas de trayectoria entonces vamos a
hacer cada una de ellas por separado
vamos a empezar con la más difícil la
más difícil es este círculo de aquí este
bueno este cuarto de círculo y entonces
es un círculo de radio 2 se parece mucho
a lo que hicimos en el vídeo pasado
entonces va a quedar algo del estilo
déjame poner con otro color para que nos
quede un poco más claro aquí lo voy a
poner con color naranja
entonces nos queda x es igual a dos
veces coseno d
y luego ya es igual a dos veces seno de
t
tenemos que darle un intervalo a la t
esto simplemente lo que hicimos en el
vídeo pasado pero ahora el círculo es de
radio 2 pero es la misma idea que se
mueve desde cero hasta el año que lo
está escribiendo mal a ver cero menor o
igual que te menor o igual que y misma
idea 90° espí medios listo este
esencialmente es el ángulo que se va
recorriendo conforme nos movemos en la
trayectoria ok entonces como le hice
para construir esto puede ser un poco
confuso si no te acuerdas de cómo hacer
ecuaciones paramétricas si es tu caso te
recomiendo ver los otros vídeos para
aprender a parametrizar bueno vamos a
encontrar la superficie sobre esta
trayectoria circular eventualmente vamos
a tener que encontrar unas derivadas con
respecto a t hagamos las de una vez de x
dt es igual a la derivada de dos coseno
dt con respecto a t es menos dos veces
en lo de t y la otra de jett pues es
igual a dos veces coseno dt porque la
derivada de kosheh no es menos seno y la
de seno es coseno va entonces si
queremos encontrar la superficie de esta
pared naranja entonces pues puedes ir
dos vídeos atrás para ver de dónde
sacamos la fórmula pero lo que hay que
hacer es tomar la integral desde cero
hasta pi entre dos de nuestra función de
x + d cuadrada
y luego hay que multiplicar por d s es
decir el pequeño cambio la f ya nos dio
la altura y el pequeño cambio nos va a
dar el ancho entonces le vamos a llamar
de ese pero ya sabemos que podemos
reescribir eso como la raíz cuadrada
déjame poner un poco de paréntesis para
poner bien el orden de las operaciones
de de x entre de t al cuadrado verdad
entonces nos queda menos dos veces seno
de t elevado al cuadrado más la derivada
de ye con respecto al t al cuadrado dos
veces coseno de t elevado al cuadrado
dt listo eso nos va a dar la sección
naranja y después nos vamos a ocupar de
las otras dos paredes pero vamos a
acabar con esta cómo podemos simplificar
esta expresión eso nos va a quedar igual
a la integral de cero aquí entre 2 de x
más cuadrada sabes que como ya estamos
poniendo todo en términos de t pues de
una vez vamos a cambiarla xy la aie por
su parametrización x es igual a dos
veces coseno de te lo escribo aquí dos
veces
dt y luego hay que sumar ya o sea dos
veces seno de t2 seno de t y eso de ahí
elevado al cuadrado para eso hay que
multiplicarlo por bs es decir esta raíz
ahí va vamos a copiarla aquí abajo se ve
como que un poco difícil pero ahorita
vamos a ver que en realidad no es tan
complicada y entonces nos queda cuatro
veces seno cuadrado de t más cuatro
veces coseno cuadrado de t ahora pues va
a pasar algo padre cuando factor izamos
el 4 verdad déjame hacer esto aquí abajo
aquí pongo el dt entonces vamos a hacer
simplemente esta expresión para no
reescribir toda la integral y entonces
nos va a quedar la raíz cuadrada de 4
por seno cuadrado de t más coseno
cuadrado de t esto es muy bueno seno
cuadrado más coseno cuadrado siempre da
1 entonces se simplifica a la raíz de 4
que es un 2
entonces toda esta raíz es un 2 eso está
muy bonito verdad
vamos a seguir con la cuenta aquí abajo
entonces a ver vamos a copiar la
integral común
como la integral de 0 a medios
de haber déjame dejar algo claro antes
pusimos está parametrización porque fue
la más simple que se me ocurrió pero
puede ser que otra parametrización
también cubra esa trayectoria si te
encuentras otra no importa si haces las
cuentas con calma y todo sale bien
entonces al final te debería de dar el
mismo resultado pero bueno sigamos aquí
abajo con la parametrización que ya
tenemos que según yo es pues una de las
más fáciles y entonces se va a
simplificar a lo siguiente nos queda
cuatro veces coseno de t y luego hay que
multiplicar pues haber dos por esta cosa
al cuadrado dos veces seno de al
cuadrado es cuatro por seno cuadrado de
t entonces es más cuatro seno cuadrado
de t pero no hay que olvidar este dos va
entonces este 2 lo ponemos aquí nos
queda un 8
y pues toda esta expresión hay que
ponerle a un dt ba seno cuadrado de t
parece que va a ser difícil de integrar
pero aquí nos salva una identidad
trigonométricas seno cuadrado de lo que
sea digamos de eeuu es igual a un medio
de uno menos coseno de dos veces uno
entonces podemos usar esta identidad
para cuando hubo es igual a t entonces
aquí podemos poner t es igual a un medio
de uno menos coseno de 2 t y entonces
vamos a reescribir la integral con esta
identidad trigonométricas obtenemos la
integral de 0 y medios de haber nos
queda cuatro veces coseno de t y a eso
tenemos que sumarle 8 por esta expresión
otra vez esta expresión de aquí es lo
mismo que seno cuadrado por lo de la
identidad trigonométricas 8 por un medio
es 4 y luego hay que multiplicar por 1 -
coseno de dos veces este simplemente
usamos una identidad trigonométricas de
t
sale esto de aquí ya parece más o menos
fácil de integrar vamos a ver si es
cierto entonces vamos a tomar la anti
derivada nos queda a ver la anti
derivada de cuatro veces coseno de t eso
simplemente es cuatro veces en lo de te
va cuatro veces seno de t el 4 era una
constante verdad entonces era nada más
la anti derivada de kossen vamos a
distribuir este 4 aquí nos quedan 4 y lo
hay que restar cuatro veces coseno de 2
t
y entonces la anti derivada de 4 es 4 t
y luego tenemos que anti derivar menos
cuatro veces coseno de 2 t haber dejar
de hacer un poquito de cuentas mentales
por aquí va a tener que ver pues
seguramente con senos de 2 t le pongo
seno de 2 t y ahora como que me tienen
que quedar las cuentas a ver cuando
derivó seno me me quedan 12 afuera
entonces para que nos queden las cuentas
hay que poner un -2 a ver vamos a ver si
es cierto la derivada de menos dos veces
seno de 2 t la diva de adentro es 2 con
lo de afuera es menos 4 y luego la
derivada de se nos conoce nueva york en
lo de adentro es coseno de 2 t listo
entonces encontramos la anti derivada y
ya nada más tenemos que evaluar desde
cero hasta pi medios vamos a las
cuentitas entonces vamos a escribir aquí
abajo lo que obtenemos a ver nos queda
cuatro veces seno de iu entre dos y
luego hay que sumar cuatro veces y entre
dos eso simplemente es dos veces pi y
luego hay que restar dos veces
de 2 y entre 2 es decir seno de pi y
luego a eso tenemos que restarle la
expresión evaluada en 0 va a quedar muy
fácil verdad fíjate seno de cero es 0
luego 4 x 0 pues también da cero y aquí
tenemos seno de dos veces cero que es
cero
entonces nos quedan puros ceros
y vamos a simplificar un poco estos
números seno de pi medios primeros es 90
grados seno de 90 grados es 1 pues aquí
ponemos 1 y seno de pies 0 entonces este
de aquí se cancela y que nos queda nos
queda cuatro más dos pi listón con eso
logramos encontrar el área de la pared
curva que habíamos pintado de color azul
la verdad eso de ahí va a ser la parte
más difícil vamos a pasar a las otras
dos curvas vamos a empezar con esta con
la de atrás vas a ver que va a ser mucho
mucho más fácil porque nuestra
parametrización va a ser un poco más
sencilla entonces vamos a tomar esta
curva de aquí
sabes que no voy a acabar de marcar pero
mejor hacemos ya las cuentas en el
siguiente vídeo porque creo que
últimamente mis vídeos se están quedando
más o menos largos hasta la próxima